[音楽]
ます
選手私の学校で期末考査が終わりました
テスト前生徒の会話に耳を傾けるとこういう声が聞こえてきます
私数学1丁わからん者もこのテスト終わったもう一人の生徒が入りました
youtube が今全部の科目とロッド系
ほんと見てみる
高校生の間でそういう会話だあー交わされるほど
今ではインターネット誘導が狩猟というは当たり前のものに失いつつあります
皆さん堀ががません太尾を申します
福岡県の公立高校で教員をやっています強化
世界史です世界史のほかにも後にもし味もを教えています
公立高校の教員といえばいろんな学校を経験することになりますが私は今までロング4
の学校を経験しました
初めは特別支援学校で障害の重い
この教育に当たりました
そして
中にはですね
教育コーナー公と言われるようなあなた高校の桜授業がままならない学校もを口にした
こともあります
そしてて次戦が工房こういったことがあります
私はそういったセットと接していると
まあ高校生というのはいろんな個性の持ち主が痛い
いろんなビーズをたたえて生活しているなというのが実感できます
私は日々のな授業の中でこうした
勉強は決して得意ではないかもしれないそういう生徒たちに50分の四季をねー
10分でも5分でも30秒でもいい歴史の面白さや歴史の奥深さ
そういうのを渡ってほしいそういう思い音授業に取り組んでまいりました
私はもう一つの顔を持っていますそれがああ
授業動画を開けているうゆチューバーだということです
なんで後方の教員がしかも県立高校の先生が
ユーチューバー親というのという質問が聞かれそうですが
5年ぐらい前ですかね a
ある学校からある学校ウェイ人児童になったときに
出て行った今の学校の生徒が私に誓うてこう言うんです
先生なんで行っちゃうの
ごめんねー
先生たちにとって神乳童貞はつきものなんな
と私はございました
10に2年生の時にして外相を教わって3年生の続きが阿蘇はれると思っていたのに
受験一緒にがんばり語ったのに
4個目が
先生は場所学校に教えに来てよ
週一でもいいからさ
いやごめんな
次の学校でも部活もあるかもしれないし
次の顔のセットにも一生懸命教えなきゃいけないごめんね時間的余裕がないんだよ
せめて
youtube
そんな方法があったのかと思いましたそれから私は思い至って世界史の授業動画就任
する
世界新三種のプロジェクトというものを始めましたはじめは前も学校の生徒のために
上げていた動画なんですけれどもええそれからいろんな方に見てもらいました高校生
受験生誰が大学生そして社会人の学び直し
こういったと思います
を辞めちゃったんだけれども大学に行きたいから見てますか
留学し聞いて日本に戻ってきて大学を受けないんだけれども
誰も歴史を教えてくれないから見てます
まあそういったいろんな人のニーズを満たすというのがわかってい
今では再生回数1000万回を超えるようなチャンネルに成長させていただきました
去年の夏にはああ
私の動画修行のエッセンスが詰まった本文を出させていただきました
このように私は
公立高校の先生と言うかをとっ
授業動画を上げているユーチューバーという2つの顔があるのです
こういった立場に立っている人というのは私以外ではあまり
見たことがありません同僚の先生ても youtube なってるよという先生はあー
わかりませんですから
この両者の立場になっている私の立場というのはかなりオリジナルなものだと思います
今日はあそういった私の視点から授業動画たアーユーチューブが教育にパターン
になる効果についてお話ししたいと思います
このような私にいろんな人と上げます
youtube と学校教育どちらいいんですか
youtube があれば授業どうかがあれば
学校ペイはいらなくなるんですかと
私にとっては
その質問はどうでもいい質問なんです
目の前の生徒が歴史って面白いな
歴史て奥深いな歴史の叡智にもっとふれないな
そういうことを守ってくれるんだったら手段は
どうでもいいんですどちらでもいいんです
[拍手]
むしろ今まで学校教育がてが黒たなかった部分が
youtube による動画授業だったら手が届くようになった
そのような
学校教育の
授業動画というのは対立する関係ではなく
学校教育を保障する支援する役割ををこの youtube による動画修行というの
は赤く染めていると思います
ではどういったところが今までも学校教育では手が届かなかったところなんでしょうか
私たちが日頃を接する生
クラスの生徒いうのは40人います
その40人の生徒に対して
私たちは一生懸命授業をやります
勉強だったら製品が分かるようになんとか繊維にわかってほしい
そういう修行します
クラス系だったら40人が製品グラスにな死んじゃうし
そういう思い一心でやっています
私以外の先生も本当に一生懸命やっていると思います
しかし学校というのはいろんな個性の持ち主が集まったばです
ですから
授業で言えばどこかも
レベルに合わせるしかないんです
クラスで言えば
それを集団として捉えるしかないんです
結果的に学校教育とはどういう場になってしまうかというと
経平均85点を求めるような悪そういう場になってしまう
クラスであれば
盗聴圧力の強い場合はどうしてもなってしまいますね
拍手ありの政府はこの学校教育に適用することができます
影響は一生懸命やし
クラスの生活も楽しいと言うしかし面談などをしてみると2割の生徒がいろんな理由で
学校に馴染めな学校に行きづらいと感じています
なんかではこれらの成分の中には
私に先生
学校やめたいんですけどっていう生徒がいます
そういう言われた時の担任の先生どう
非常に行くらしい
引き裂かれるような思いというのは担任の先生でないとわからないくらいのものです
しかしここに授業動画があればどうでしょうか
例えば学校教育の中で
成績がなかった伸び悩むいうでもテスト前だ
そういう時に主要動画を見ることによって分かりやすく教えてくれる企業様が見ること
によって
このみんなでを補うことができます
あるいはあああ
息が高すぎて学校教育に対して
を守っている数姿勢と思います不可能額をしてきたようなパー1
いる者です
そういう場合も大学レベルにあった主婦受けたい大学になった
動画をどんどん見ることができます
そして集団がにいません a という精度も応じよう動画だから
一対一で教えてくれます
あるいは完全に不登校になってしまうしまっても
動画修行を受けて高卒認定試験を受ければ大学に行くチャンスも生まれます
私はこういうことさえ想像します
インターネット小児歯科も youtube ねー
すべての科目が上がっている
私のような社会化だけではなくて国語や理科
そして保険が家庭科に至るまでセブ youtube でわかっていて誰もがそれを
視聴可能であろう
そしてその指導がの主張によって履修を認め
レポートの提出によって単位を認めるならば
誰でも格安ですー c 制高校が開けるということです
これは教育のこそダムと教育の可用性に非常に良い
駅するものををもなるはずです
うつの可能性を考えてみましょう
インターネットによる動画修行というのはイノベーションの芽を育てることもできます
ここに非常に天才ただの少年がいるとしましょう
彼は物理に非常に興味を持っています
日頃から物理を本ばっかり読むものの運動や電気電子そういうものを一ゴロずっと考え
たいそういう制度ですそれがもし高校に入ってみるとどうでしょうか
あればテストで物理では満点
しかし他は赤点です
そういった時高校の先生たちは彼の赤点をなくすように
一生懸命になるんです
彼に課題が与えられ
補修お客さんを行うということをするでしょう
そうすると彼は
肝心の物理に没頭できる時間がそうした
いろんな課題やいろんな募集っていうものに追われてしまって感じの[ __ ]の物理の才能を
伸ばすというチャンスが失われてしまうわけです
結局彼にとって学校はできずない場所になる
彼の一番の武器である物理というものの才能が埋没してしまうでしょう
しかしインパネ組よる動画修行があれば
例えば彼がだ
小学校の時に美化に興味があるとします
学校の授業動画高校の始業動画撮っどんどん今
レッドで見ることができます興味の赴くままにいろんな動画を見やサルでしょう
そして今では大学レベルの研究や大学レベルの論文というものもインターネット理解っ
ている時代です
彼はこのようにしてどんどん知識を吸収したい
結果的に出来上がる人会というのが
外尾
あまりできないかもしれないけども物理だけは200点とか300円というような糖質
した天才肌になる子がいありません
そうした糖質した天才肌の人材が
たとえ
ナノテクノロジーの分野あるいは半導体や超年度といった分野でイノベーションを
起こすことができるのです
今まで学校教育というのはそうした県債からを育てきれなかったんです
もう一つの多能性を考えております
インターネットによる授業動画は学校教育から社会での教養への橋渡しをすることが
できます
私は高校で社会科を教えています
社会化というのは社会の
成り立ちがあらもしを教える科目ですしかし高校生は究極のところ
社会死んではありませんまた社会に出てみませんですので金融について教えたので
異文化や世界史を教えたとあるいは権利や民主主義を教えたって
高校生は
深いところではピンと来てないんです
彼らが
社会人になったとき
お金を扱ってみてはじめてイッ
自分とは違った超式を持った大丈夫もう人とコミュニケーションしてビジネスをそして
はじめ
そして
自分が不利な立場に追いやられ始めている
健勇についてお金について基礎から勉強してみようか
世界の歴史兄文化について学んでみようか
あるいは県や wish について勉強しよう
そういう気が社会の中で初めて起こるんです
社会科という科目は社会の中で必ず
学び直しが必要な科目なんです
しかし今まで学校教育というのは卒業させたら
せっぱなしてみましょうかああ
その後まで面倒を見るということは
して来なかったんですしかしインターネットにより動画主様があればいつでもだれでも
学ぶ直しができるんです
私の
動画授業も
半数以上の人が二十歳以上の大人の人に見てもらっています
こういうことからもうインターネルー融合が授業は
学びな二死というものに関して非常に有効なことがわかります
このように見てきますと
インターネットによる動画修行というのは社会がさまざまな部分に橋を架けていること
が分かります
今までなく公共いくら手が届かなかったところにいろんな橋を架け
行くことができます
ええっ
肢は多い方がいいと思います私は現場の先生たちにもっともっと
ローハブをネット上に投げてほしいなというふうにそう思います
学校現場だけでそのノウハウを落としこめるのではなく
優れた都市へから優れた実践というものをどんどん
youtube でもこう古庄の形でも
ネット上に公開してほしいと思っています
学校の先生というのは
毎日人にものを教えていくという優れたコンテンツを超えたばかりです
私の学校にも
私なんか足元にも及ばないぐらいスプレーが実践をしている先生がたくさんいます
そういった先生に関学校教育のバッだけでその脳波落とし込めておかずみ
どんどん公開してほしいというふうに思っています
私は明日も朝1時間目から授業があります
これから a
効果に戻って授業の宿したいと思う
思っています
これからも私は
学校教育の中で割っ
液晶一生懸命教えてせ
成功の教養への
扉を着たからそして
インターネットで様々なコンテンツ書を上げることによっていっ
教養への架け橋をたくさん
沢山
かけていきたいとおもいます
ドンありがとうございました
ええええええ